♪ ♪
>> HEALTH OFFICIALS SAYING GIVEN
THE NATURE OF THE PRIMARY, GIVEN
KIND OF THE WAY YOU GO IN AND DO
ONE MOST OF THE TIME FOR MOST
COUNTIES, IT CAN BE DONE SAFELY.
>> Martha: INSISTING AND SAFER
FOR THEIR VOTERS TO HEAD TO THE
POLLS TOMORROW, DESPITE MORE
THAN 150 CONFIRMED CASES OF
CORONAVIRUS IN FLORIDA.
BIDEN AND SANDERS COME UP WITH
CAMPAIGNS TO VIRTUAL EVENTS ALSO
SQUARING OFF IN ARIZONA,
ILLINOIS, AND NOW OHIO AS
DESPITE GOVERNOR WE SPOKE WITH
EARLIER PRESSING TO DELAY IT.
OF FLORIDA SENATOR RICK SCOTT
WE’VE SEEN NOW, SELF-QUARANTINE
THREE DAYS AFTER HE CAME IN
CONTACT WITH BRAZIL’S PRESIDENT
WHOSE AID IT TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US, AND
FIRST OF ALL, HOW ARE YOU DOING
AND HOW MUCH LONGER WILL YOU BE
SELF-QUARANTINE TO?
>> THIS IS MY EIGHTH DAY, AND
I’VE NEVER TAKEN MY TEMPERATURE
AS MUCH OF TAKEN IT THE LAST FEW
AND I SAY THAT PRETTY
CONSISTENTLY, THE FIRST THING
THAT HAPPENED.
NOT THE MOST FUN THING TO DO,
BUT I LIKE MY FAMILY AND I LIKE
MY WORKPLACE SO I’D LIKE TO BE
CALLING ON MAYORS, HOSPITAL
ASSISTANTS, DOCTORS, CALLING
CHAIRS AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BETA
>> Martha: PERSONAL QUESTION
FIRST, WHERE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS AND WE’VE BEEN ASKED NOW TO
STAY PUT LIKE YOU HAVE.
FOR 15 DAYS, YOU KNOW, VERY
HARD-CORE WAY IN ORDER TO KIND
OF GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF A
BREATHER HERE.
HOW DO YOU THINK AMERICANS ARE
GOING TO DO WITH THIS OVER THE
LONG TERM?
>> I THINK AMERICANS WILL SHOW
UP AND LOOK, WE’VE GOT TO DO
SOME EXTREME THINGS HERE BECAUSE
YOU’RE RIGHT, YOU’RE TALKING
ABOUT IT WERE GOING THE PATH OF
SOUTH KOREA OR GOING THE PATH OF
ITALY.
THE PATH OF SOUTH KOREA, BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO GET THIS TESTING UP
THIS WEEK.
WE WILL DO RAPID TEST AND WE’VE
GOT TO SECURE THE FORCE AND
THAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
OUR GOVERNORS HAVE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY CAN GET SOCIAL
DISTANCING WAY BETTER THAN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WE’VE GOT
TO TAKE CARE OF OF OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND THE
PROTECTED TO GEAR AND FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN PROTECT AND GOSH, WHY
ARE WE -- WHY WAS ANYBODY PRICE
GOUGING.
I TURN HER GENITALS HAVE TO SHOW
UP AND STOP THAT
>> Martha: BUT YOU FEEL THAT
EQUIPMENT IS DOING, ALL THAT I
THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE
SURPRISED THAT SOME PLACES DON’T
HAVE WHAT THEY NEED.
>> DEPENDS ON WHAT YOU ARE, AND
BLOOD, HEALTH CARE
IS A LOCAL DELIVERED SYSTEM.
WITH LOCAL HEALTH CARE
DEPARTMENTS AND POSITIONS, THEY
HAVE TO GET TOGETHER AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT CAN THEY PRODUCE THAT
MAYBE THEY DON’T HAVE.
IS THERE EQUIPMENT THAT WE CAN
PUT THE WORK THAT’S BEING USED
FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
WE’VE GOT TO BE VERY GREAT LOCAL
FOR STATE AND WE’VE GOT TO TAKE
CARE THE REGULATIONS MIGHT MAKE
SENSE AT A DIFFERENT TIME BUT
WERE IN A CRISIS.
WE’VE GOT TO DO IT TOGETHER,
IT’S YOUR PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIGURE IT OUT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CANNOT
SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM AND WE’VE
GOT TO HAVE OUR FAMILIES, OUR
CHURCHES, OUR MAYORS, OUR
COMMUNITIES, WE’VE GOT TO GET
TOGETHER ON THIS AND SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
THIS IS A LOCAL PROBLEM RIGHT
NOW, IT’S A LOCAL HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
>> Martha: VERY QUICKLY, DO
YOU THINK IT’S THE RIGHT
DECISION TO GO AHEAD AND HOLD
THE PRIMARY TOMORROW?
YOU FEEL SAFE ABOUT THAT?
>> MARTHA, FLORIDA, YOU CAN VOTE
EARLY AND BY ABSENTEE AND WHEN
YOU CAN SUPERVISE YOUR ELECTION,
IF A CONCERN CALL YOUR ELECTION
AND SAYING HOW ARE YOU KEEPING